cuentas de que soñamos con vivir en un
mundo de paz y en un mundo sostenible
que levante la mano
harto cierto como usted yo comparto este
sueño y esto es lo que me motivó hace 10
años a empezar un rumbo a entender cómo
podía yo aportar ya sea desde la empresa
desde un trabajo desde el emprendimiento
como podía las personas comunes y
corrientes como apoyar las empresas
aportar y ser parte de un cambio
positivo y hacernos cargo de los
desafíos que tenía el mundo y esta
búsqueda comenzó ya no tengo ya recuerdo
exactamente cuando siempre tenía
intereses en temas sociales en temas
ambientales pero todo se gatilló el año
2011 caminando por la universidad un
destacado profesor que estaba armando un
magíster es entonces dice no de aquí en
la universidad van a salir los nuevos
facebook los nuevos google van a salir
emprendimientos de rup tivos chile tiene
todo el potencial para x sacamos todas
las soluciones que hacen falta en el
mundo
pero no me vengan con proyectos sociales
no me vengan con proyectos sociales que
salvar al mundo no da de comer estas
cosas y de hacerse cargo de las
caridades de los proyectos sociales está
bien pero como un hobby no se dediquen a
eso porque ahí no está la innovación ahí
no está el emprendimiento
qué impacto me quedé paralizado y es ya
admira este profesor pero estoy
totalmente en desacuerdo con lo que hice
como es que no vamos a hacer pues vamos
a poder ser capaces de innovar y de
emprender y atender todos los desafíos
globales
así es que nos dicen que no nos
dediquemos a eso que eso no nos da de
comer
entonces empecé a decir
espera y si yo puedo comprobar que esto
no es cierto me sentí desafiadas y
empecé a pensar yo soy una mujer
inteligente conozco mucha gente
inteligente me gusta mucho el
emprendimiento me gusta mucho la
innovación qué pasa si yo voy a buscar a
aquellas personas que están haciendo eso
y le pruebo a ese profesor que está aquí
ok entonces un poquito rebelde me metí y
se mi tesis de magíster buscando algo
que comprobará que eso no era cierto y
empecé mi búsqueda entonces a
relacionarme con las empresas de
a entender nuevos modelos empresariales
a entender nuevas innovaciones
pero no era suficiente que me pasaba
cada vez que más entendía el problema
más profundo se hacía y me empezaba a
angustiar porque me sentía soy un grano
de arena tratando de parar un tsunami
como yo soy capaz de con tan pocas cosas
parar un cambio tan grande que hay que
hacer en el mundo
entonces primero como bien nos enseñan
metí primero la cabeza en este modelo
que nos han enseñado lógico-matemático
primero la razón y luego el corazón
empecé a investigar bien pero qué se
puede hacer entonces cuál es la razón
del problema cuáles son las soluciones
que existen
entonces
el primero que entendimos fue que las
cosas como las veníamos haciendo ya no
da para más esta economía alineando
nosotros extraemos recursos fabricamos
bienes y productos los disponemos los
usamos y luego se transforman en basura
es imposible es un modelo que está
basado en tener recursos y en tener un
mundo infinito cuando no es así cuando
tenemos recursos finitos
entonces apareció luego a el reciclaje
de genial le podemos dar un segundo
ciclo a los productos y servicios pero
es eso suficiente no hacemos que los
productos servicios vuelvan a circular
pero el problema nos acaba genial
entonces será que la economía circular
es entonces la solución buenísimo
generamos un ciclo donde solo los
recursos y los productos dan vueltas y
vueltas y no se genera basura por lo
tanto nos empezamos a acercar al modelo
natural donde la basura de uno es el
alimento de otro si conceptualmente hace
razón y es cierto pero eso es suficiente
y qué pasaba si yo quería estar
trabajando en reciclaje y qué pasaba con
los desafíos sociales significaba que si
mi causa era ambiental no podía ser
social también como conversamos con
amigos no lo mi tema es 100% social yo
me meto en educación pero no no no
reciclo no
no comía orgánica como que no cacho esa
onda o no yo soy así greenpeace abrazó
árboles el tema social no así pero como
que eso será problema de los políticos o
las fundaciones y esa pero qué pasa si a
mí me importa todo un poquito ambiciosa
qué pasa si no quería además de poder
generar cero basura también quería
romper estereotipos de género qué pasa
si yo quería ser feminista pero también
estar metidos en los problemas de salud
porque estamos llenos de ojo o era
social o era ambiental o metí en temas
culturales o metían temas sociales y así
yo quería dejar de que existieran esos
ojos y empezaron a suceder esos y qué
pasa si podía ser ambiental y social
y que pasaba que mientras más y más me
metía en este mundo sobre todo los
últimos seis años de carrera profesional
mientras más investigada que estaba
pasando más lejos se veía la solución y
más angustiada decía ya voy a dejarlo
todo voy a volverme una ermitaña muy en
la montaña casi que no voy a producir
voy a carbono porque qué voy a hacer si
en verdad no hay vuelta atrás vemos las
noticias y todo el escenario es
imposible el día que empezamos a
consumir nos los recursos del año
siguiente cada año son más cercanos el
2011 y el 2012 eran en noviembre y este
año fueron en agosto o sea el primer día
de agosto se nos acabaron los recursos
planetarios y empezamos a usar los del
año siguiente como era posible que
nosotros como sociedad habíamos creado
tantos avances tecnológicos increíbles
tenemos un ciclo de día ahora larguísimo
tenemos una salud como nunca antes
tenemos una conectividad del mundo total
yo puedo ahora mantener relaciones con
amigas en taiwán si quiero en tiempo
real
puedo tener un sistema de salud el
sistema de educación digital pero a qué
costo
hemos logrado estas cosas entonces es
cuando empieza una vez que el gráfico
que nos permite ver el aumento en
ciertos desarrollos va directamente
relacionado con el aumento en los costos
ambientales y en los costos del
planetario que hemos tenido
y eso incluso se traduce en que estamos
rompiendo ciertas barreras de seguridad
planetaria hoy día si seguimos como
estamos
va a llegar un punto en que los ya no
estén tan a significados que se acaben
los corales y los corales en los océanos
no respiran y si los océanos dejan de
respirar entonces toda la vida del
planeta se muere pero también somos
capaces de revertirlo porque entre los
años 90 cuando se dieron cuenta que
clorofluorocarbonos rompía la capa de
ozono y se hace una campaña global el
nivel de la capa de ozono se empieza a
regenerar y somos capaces de volver a
los límites planetarios
y ya esto como
lo último y es como lo más nuevo y lo
más impresionante es que estamos
nosotros por primera vez en la humanidad
una especie única está modificando la
vida sobre la faz de la tierra y estamos
entrando en lo que se conoce como el
antropoceno es una nueva era geológica
donde el mundo se está modificando por
la acción de una sola especie en este
caso los humanos entonces qué nos pasa
nos encontramos por ejemplo con esta
roca en hawai que se encontró hace
cuatro años donde tiene necesidad can
saber pero esta línea azul y esta línea
blanca son trozos de plástico es una
roca formada por una mezcla entre roca y
plástico
entonces si vemos el impacto que estamos
generando
será que también podemos ser parte de la
solución
qué pasa si ahora damos vuelta a la
pregunta y decimos en vez de que el
humano tenga que salir de la tierra y
ojalá que el humano no exista para que
la naturaleza pueda regenerarse
qué pasa si nosotros nos transformamos
en una parte positiva de este mundo y
así como podemos hacer rocas de plástico
podamos devolver la tierra la capacidad
de hacer
entonces me empecé a preguntar qué pasa
si estoy viendo la película incompleta y
por eso me gusta mucho esta imagen
porque si uno la vea así parece un
círculo completo pero es el reflejo del
agua es solo una estructura que un arco
qué pasa si en mi mente estaba viendo
las cosas al revés
qué pasa si estaba pasando desde las
cosas como un problema y la empezar a
ver como una oportunidad
qué pasa si lo que entendemos como un
problema
realmente no lo es y es solo una crisis
de percepción
entonces empecé con estas preguntas a
buscar qué pasa si estamos con el
fenómeno como esta fábula no sé si es
india o china porque ahí se pelean en la
autoría pero de estos hombres ciegos que
comienzan a tocar distintas partes del
elefante y le preguntan qué es lo que
estás qué es lo que estaba frente a ti
entonces el primer hombre ciego que toca
la oreja dice no estoy con una palma el
que toca la cola dice no esto es una
cuerda el que toca la pierna y dice no
este es un árbol todos tienen razón pero
dos también de la película completa
qué pasa si nosotros seguíamos tratando
encontrar las soluciones con la misma
manera y de la misma forma que habíamos
creado el problema por eso me gusta
mucho esta frase de albert einstein como
vamos encontrar una solución si seguimos
pensando con la misma mentalidad con la
que creamos el problema
por eso entonces leyendo varios autores
conversando y ya es una reflexión de
mucho mucho tiempo
llegamos a entender hoy día y es lo
maravilloso de la tecnología y lo
maravilloso de los conectados que está
el mundo que muchos autores al mismo
tiempo empiezan a emerger con documentos
y con conocimientos que solo hoy se sabe
y que antes no se sabía y es lo que yo
les traigo aquí para contar que es una
nueva manera de entender el mundo y
tiene tres principales factores el
primero es estamos en una red todo está
conectado y es una red interdependiente
y esta red se mueve en ciclos en ciclos
circulares
y estos ciclos circulares a medida que
van avanzando pueden generar y regenerar
vida y otras cosas
entonces qué significa que estamos en
red
se acuerdan que estamos conversando que
todas las crisis uno tiene que elegir si
era o social o ambiental que pasa si
pudiésemos mapear todos los desafíos
globales y los pudiésemos poner en un
solo mapa es eso posible
esta gente tenía el desafío y lo lograr
tanto brown como después fritjof capra y
llegan a un diagrama así que no se ve
tanto
créanme que está bien hecho
tiene conectados todos los desafíos
globales y se entienden como todos
partes de una misma red los desafíos
ambientales que llevan a desafíos
sociales por ejemplo hoy día tenemos
mucha mayor migración por el clima que
por cualquier guerra en nunca antes en
la historia la humanidad
entonces tenemos problemas de terrorismo
por ejemplo asociado a la escasez de
alimentos asociado al cambio climático
asociados al cambio temperatura
asociados a la forma de cómo
consideramos alimentos asociados al
volumen de personas que estamos
habitando el planeta y así estamos en
una red absolutamente interconectada y
así como los problema están conectados
sucede lo mismo la naturaleza todas las
especies forman una red el metabolismo
una bacteria forma una red nuestro link
y fueron una red
vivimos en un mundo absurdamente
interdependiente y esta red lo
maravilloso es que funciona de manera
circular todos los recursos tienen un
ciclo el carbono que emite una planta lo
toma un árbol lo transforma en oxígeno
es oxígeno alimenta y ustedes ya todos
conocen las punto síntesis el ciclo del
agua todos los ciclos naturales son
ciclos todo funciona y todo tiene una
razón de ser si lo no existe para qué
y esta circularidad también permite que
genere los y se regenere la vida sobre
la tierra por ejemplo durante 10.000
años de agricultura extensiva en china
un área que se llama 'el es plato de 640
mil kilómetros cuadrados
fue declarada desierto porque no se
podía hacer nada y era ya una tierra que
no tenía era solo arena hasta que en
1995 el banco mundial coloca un fondo
agrupa el gobierno chino a varias
instituciones la sociedad civil y
suponen el desafío de empezar a
recuperar esta extensión de tierra y en
un plazo de diez años han recuperado no
la totalidad pero casi un 30%
permitiendo que la misma tierra se
regenere solo volviendo a colocar los
elementos que estaban ahí originalmente
los árboles las plantas con la
acumulación de agua y la tierra sucede
cómo es que la red logra esto entonces
cómo es que sabemos que está todo en red
todo es circular y podemos generar y
regenerar vida en esta red cómo es que
lo logra y un fenómeno muy bonito han
visto estos estos nubes de pájaros estas
bandas organizadas o los cardúmenes por
separado cada uno de estos de estas aves
no sabe para dónde ir no es que tenga
mayor un plan o una hoja de ruta
pero cuando tan todas juntas se
organizan y van tomando las redes del
viento las temperaturas las presiones
sean movilizando cuando tocan ciertas
estaciones todas migran lo mismo los
cardúmenes de peces todos se organizan
cuando viene un depredador
cómo es que lo logra la red esto y un
fenómeno que ahora estamos entendiendo y
se llama emergencia significa y cuando
la suma de las partes es mayor y es
mejor y es diferente que la suma de las
cosas individualmente entonces nos queda
el cardumen todas las consciencias a los
peces se pongan de acuerdo y las sumemos
linealmente es que estando todos juntos
así como todos los humanos emerge algo
nuevo que no estábamos entendiendo
entonces si encontramos una manera en
que los humanos entendamos que somos una
red que está en este mundo y que somos
parte de como el mundo funciona podemos
entender una manera de convivir como
dice el doctor maturana y entonces vamos
a permitir que la vida sea con nosotros
en ella también con la tecnología que
hemos desarrollado también
cuál es esta red entonces que nos tiene
que preocupar me gusta poner preocupar
con el pre entre paréntesis porque no
quiero que sea algo que alguien va a
ocuparse mañana yo que quiero ocupar
aquí y ahora cuál es la red que nos
tiene que ocupar hoy en nuestro planeta
tierra
este es el único planeta que tenemos es
el único donde estamos aquí y ahora es
lo único que sabemos que permite la vida
como estamos por ejemplo estamos aquí
entonces viene la pregunta qué es lo que
queremos sostener
queremos obtener entonces esta red
porque si lo vemos como es naturalmente
incluso en este ejercicio que hizo david
látimer él colocó hace 65 años estas
pequeñas plantas dentro de esta jarra y
lo tapó y desde entonces los regalos
sólo dos veces con dos cucharadas de
agua y la vida florece y no necesitan
nada más eso es lo que tenemos que
nosotros lograr qué es lo que queremos
obtener queremos obtener la vida en la
tierra con nosotros en ella
pero ahora viene la pregunta ya y cómo
lo hacemos cómo nos ponemos de acuerdo
entonces maravillosamente hace dos años
193 países por primera vez en el mundo
se ponen de acuerdo y decimos bien
tenemos desafíos globales que tenemos
que atender nos tenemos que poner de
acuerdo
y fijamos los 17 objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible pero si se fijan los volvemos
a ver de nuevo aquí en cuadraditos
encendidas todos paraditos ordenaditos
pero como me gusta a mí verlo y no es
autoría me da por supuesto alguien más
ya lo hizo lo pensantes que hay una
manera de ver estos objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible de forma sistémica
y es verlo así nuestros desafíos
económicos están insertos dentro de una
sociedad y esta sociedad está sujeta a
límites planetarios esta es la manera
que entendemos tenemos que entender los
desafíos de los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible y los desafíos globales que
tenemos que atender
pero y qué hago yo ahora que pueden
ustedes empezar a hacer aquí y ahora
desde el momento en que se pare de estas
sillas y salgan de esta sala y fue una
pregunta que me carcomía cada vez que yo
a estas charlas y sustentabilidad sí
genial entiendo por qué hago yo qué hago
yo aquí ahora entonces empecé y este es
mi objetivo qué es lo que hace que el
emprendimiento que tengo y todo
el objetivo de la producción de consumo
sostenible gran parte de los problemas
que tenemos se generan por cómo estamos
organizados en nuestra sociedad de
consumo que pueda ser yo distinto
entonces todo el tiempo estamos tomando
decisiones de consumo y todo el tiempo
estamos votando con el dinero que
colocamos con cada producto o servicio
que nosotros usamos desde que me levanto
que medio transporte voy a usar que
estoy comiendo qué ropa me voy a poner
dónde estoy dejando la plata a quién
quién está detrás cómo es esa empresa
que está haciendo cómo lo está haciendo
por qué lo está haciendo estos son todas
las preguntas que me motivan a mí en
cada momento de las compras ese puede
ser incluso un poquito obsesivo
pero esa es una algo concreto una acción
que me permite comenzar una reflexión
que me lleva a entender una nueva visión
del mundo y me lo que me gusta pensar es
que porque estoy terminando esta charla
aquí que formamos aquí y ahora una nueva
red de la cual puede emerger algo que
nadie sabe bien que va a suceder pero
espero que nos sirva a todos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]